Le site de Miller envoie toujours des pings rassurants,
celui de Mann aussi.
Le site de Miller reste encourageant, non ?
On sera bientôt dessus.
Mais y a une petite complication :
tenter d'y atterrir serait dangereux,
il y a une force gravitationnelle colossale
qui émane d'un tel trou noir.
La gravité de cette planète va ralentir notre horloge–
Yes !
Décalage horaire !
Ça je l'ai eu une fois parce que j'étais allé
aux States avec mes parents,
et par exemple en France il est 16h et au Texas
il est genre 22h, par exemple.
Et bien chaque heure passée sur cette planète
équivaudra à...
sept années sur notre vieille Terre.
Ah ouais ok,
donc rien à voir en fait,
ça c'est comme les années de chien,
donc du coup je propose de PAS
aller sur cette planète...
Du tout.
À peine parti, à peine revenu
on économise un temps dingue.
Ça, ça marchera.
Si c'est l'affaire de plusieurs années,
j'aurai le temps d'étudier la gravité.
Ouais,
je pense qu'on va avoir bien le temps de faire plein de trucs, là.
Largage.
Au revoir Ranger.
Ouais euh, au revoir,
et puis essayez de vous magner aussi,
parce que comme nous c'est
fois sept...
Même dix minutes de retard
ça nous fout dedans direct.
Donc euh, tracez, avec le...
Parce que...
Bonjour Romy.
Ça fait des années que j'attends.
Combien d'années ?
23 ans ! Ça fait 23 ans qu'on se gèle les couilles ici
et qu'on se fait bien chier, donc...
Merci.
Je t'ai vu dans cette prison
et tu étais perdu.
Tu étais mon meilleur disciple.
Tu devrais aujourd'hui être à mes côtés
pour sauver le monde.
Ma place je vais la prendre.
Entre vous et les habitants de Gotham.
Personne ne peut sauver Gotham.
Ok c'est bon les gars,
vous pouvez préparer le feu là.
Quand une forêt devient trop sauvage
Une purification par le feu me semble
inévitable et naturelle.
Nan mais "préparer", j'avais dit
"préparer le feu" là !
Dès demain, le monde assistera
avec horreur
à l'autodestruction de sa plus
grande ville.
Euh...
Ra's ?
En fait là ils ont lancé le feu...
J'avais dit "préparer" et du coup
en fait nous on est dedans la maison...
En fait là ils ont lancé le feu...
J'avais dit "préparer" et du coup
en fait nous on est dedans la maison...
Donc, euh...
Rien ni personne n'empêchera
le retour de l'harmonie, cette fois.
Fait chaud nan ?
Hein ? Oui...
Bah c'est l'incendie,
sûrement...
Qui génère de la chaleur,
en fait...
Ah, on se casse !
Ouais, c'est bien vu, parce que là,
vraiment ça crâme de partout donc euh...
Nan...
Nan mais sérieux...
Vous voulez pas aller parler dehors là ?
Parce que là y'a des flammes,
y'a des trucs qui s'effondrent...
Donc on la joue sécu...
Vous avez déjà attaqué cette ville
C'est pour l'achever
que nous sommes revenus !
Et cette fois aucun idéaliste
mal avisé ne nous en empêchera.
Ou alors un Skype ?
Un petit Skype tranquille à la maison...
Ou un Facetime ?
Lorsque quelqu'un veut barrer la route
à la vraie justice,
tu t'approches de lui par suprise
et tu lui poignardes le coeur !
WOW ! Ok...
Donc là il s'est pris une poutre
dans la gueule,
Donc on reste là si vous voulez,
c'est vous le boss...
Mais là, là–
Vous êtes partis.
Ok...
Nickel,
merci d'avoir prévenu...
Euh ouais donc nous on y va hein,
parce qu'on est garés devant
donc on trace.
Ciao.
Stop !
Y'a quelque chose
qui me gonfle vraiment !
On a quelqu'un qui joue faux
parmi nous.
Ouais c'est moi,
je fais n'importe quoi !
Whiplash.
Il nous faut un policier qui n'a besoin
ni de manger, ni de dormir.
Doté d'une grande puissance de feu,
et des réflexes adéquats.
Mes chers collègues,
j'ai l'honneur et le plaisir
de vous présenter le champion de la sécurité publique.
ED209.
Yes !
C'est mon invention.
Je suis chef de projet sur le truc, donc...
Ok.
L'Echo Dépisteur 209
est un robot policier entièrement autonome.
Et entièrement conçu par moi,
donc...
Il est à l'heure actuelle programmé
pour le maintient de l'ordre—
Ok, là c'est pas cool
parce que là ils allaient applaudir, je pense.
Le 209 occupera à notre avis une place essentielle
dans l'arsenal militaire de la prochaine décennie.
Ouais.
Monsieur Kinney,
braquez votre arme de façon menaçante.
Vous allez voir.
Veuillez lâcher votre arme.
Vous avez 20 secondes pour obéir.
Regarde.
Vous avez 15 secondes pour obéir.
Ouais, alors là il a jeté l'arme,
normalement faut la poser par terre.
Non non mais en fait
là comme c'est une démo, j'ai dit qu'ils mettent pas de munitions dans le—
Ouais, alors,
j'étais pas tout seul, tout seul, non plus hein,
y avait quand même eux qui m'aidaient.
Et puis, il a...
je rappelle qu'il a quand même jeté l'arme,
et normalement il faut...
Faut la poser, par terre.
Voilà.
Qu'on appelle une ambulance !